and brad if you would re-share your
screen
hello everyone and welcome to our expert
webinar
20 things you need to know now about ppc
with brad gettys uh ppc chair at
simplylearn
and a co-founder of analysis
and i'll tell you more about briada in a
moment
first i would like to mention how to use
the webex controls
and you can ask questions which
brad will answer in the q a toward the
end of the webinar by using the question
mark
button um please remember to hit
send again we probably won't be
answering a lot of those during the
webinar maybe one or two but we will be
taking
some of them at the end of the webinar
in the q a
uh you can use the chat function to send
us messages
remember to use all panelists so that we
all see it
and again hit send
send your message and
we're also going to be asking some
interactive questions
and i'd like to start with um
this one which is
two question poll what's your current
job role
and how are you feeling today we like to
do a thumbs up thumbs down
check um
we've been doing that ever since the
pandemic started just to see how people
are talking
leave the pole open just for about a
minute longer
that
i think we have a fair number of
students in the audience today
um managers as well as
marketing professionals and i'll
share the results in just a
few moments
give you about 20 seconds to finish the
poll and hit enter
and five
four three two
one
and we have a broad distribution of
people in different
functions um but mostly students
marketers managers a few executives
and it looks like
most people are thinking their things
are pretty okay today
which is good to hear so with that
i'd like to uh introduce brad
and brad as i mentioned is the ppc chair
at simply learn
uh and co-founder of analysis he's an
author and speaker a well
known and well-respected thought leader
in digital marketing
author of book advanced google adwords
and he is an accomplished speaker a
column
writer um and as i said
an industry acknowledged leader
and we're glad to have him today um so
brad
i'll turn it over to you all right
thanks stuart
and and so morning everyone or our
evening if you're uh
over in india so when when you're
talking
paid search to people there's often
questions that
come up right and that's what we're
going to kind of talk through today
is thinking through these conversations
so when you sort of say well what kind
of conversations do you have
well one of course is the job interview
right so when you think about going in
for an
interview well the company a wants to
know
you actually know what you're doing
right two
it's often a philosophy match
especially if you are replacing someone
internally where the job manager already
has a philosophy
of how their accounts are being managed
right and then three is often
adaptability right
can you adapt to change situations now
in other cases right you're the
interviewer
right so you're saying all right i'm
hiring someone new
um we need to sort of look at how our
company thinks about marketing
and make sure any candidates sort of fit
that
and then two right often you have a
client sales or client retention
and especially when these days you often
have
clients who might have managed paid
search themselves or they've been doing
this for years with an agency
so they understand the conversations but
in their
their goal is to talk with the agency to
say
well hey again do you know what you're
doing right question number one right do
we actually trust the agency or trust
the person hiring to do this for us
um two again philosophy and adaptability
so it doesn't really matter if you're a
manager talking to a potential
interviewee
um an interviewee who is going to try to
get a job
if you're a someone in in-house who's
interviewing an agency or an agency
interviewing a
potential client right all these same
questions come up in every single
situations so that they're sort of
applicable
everywhere and they're often are not
right and wrong answers right there's
often
right more how do you think about these
things
and that's what we want to kind of walk
through is looking at
sort of the pivot points of where you
should think
yeah we like this we don't like this and
why
so often you know question one that
comes up right are things like
managers or an interviewer diving super
deep to say
do you should we even continue this and
often you get into something very
specific like
do you know what about what match types
are right and and
there that's a right or wrong answer
right you know there are you know
four match types is how they work et
cetera et cetera
but then it often gets into well do you
like single keyword ad groups
some people do some people don't and
it's not an answer of like
yeah we we don't like single keyword ad
groups
right it's why oh well
it's it's you know it separates the data
out into any places it makes ad testing
a little bit harder
therefore we prefer to consolidate
things right it's that why
which is much more involved in the
thought side
what do you think about broad match
versus broad match modifier
right and again not right and wrong
answers if you're in an
english-speaking world raw match
modifier is really good if you are
doing multilingual queries broad match
has its place so again
why do you like it how do you manage
search terms
and often you'll get into a discussion
about account organization
right and so this can often get into
places where
we like to organize around budgets
or match types or product lines
or hey we we do a lot of short-term
sales so we really need to keep
campaigns out just for short-term sales
to
to quickly change them around and so
this
often sets that initial tone of
do you know what you're actually talking
about off again you're right in the
wrong answers match types
what is your overall philosophy on
organization do you take the the simple
approach which is not slightly bad right
it's just
you know let's do things very
straightforward very easy to figure out
or a very flexible approach then things
get a little more complicated
all right questions like should we bid
on our brand
and and you know it's a lot of people so
of course you should
but why is what you want to start
thinking about right
so yes we should bid on brand because we
have competitors who are bidding on
brand
therefore we want to ensure we always
maintain
you know aspect one and then there's the
smart
cmo in the room right and when you've
got the the cmo who
you know really is discerning what
they're talking about
they'll get into like really tricky
questions like
well how do we know bidding on brand
results in incremental conversions
versus what we would have gotten
if we didn't bid on brand we ranked
organically people were looking for us
anyway
and it's a very fair question right so
that gets into
have you learned enough to design a test
how do you do tests is it
hey let's use you know google's
experiments to do it
maybe we need if we're a you know
multinational company maybe we need to
do
some you know geographic split testing
what does that look like right and so
this
is often when you want to think you know
if you're interviewing for a
a entry-level job you're not going to
get this question or you might but
you're not expected to have a great
answer
right if you're interviewing for a ppc
team leader job
or you're the agency trying to get a new
client
right this is a really important
question right this shows your ability
to think through right not necessarily
a yes no but a why and how to
test and show how much you really
understand
their business and their competitors did
you do your research before you had a
conversation
then you often get into things hey
google always says we should use
responsive search ads and display search
chats
right should we and again there's not
right and wrong answers here
right it's um you're in a highly
regulated industry
rsa sometimes run into regulatory
problems
therefore if you're a financial company
in a country with a lot of regulation
things going on you might want to skip
them right
and again it's not just that are these
good or bad
how does that affect that client or that
person or that company you're talking
with
i'm um dynamic search ads again
google believes you should always use
them should you
right and again this is worth thinking
through
not just this is how it works right but
yes you have a huge website
we can't cover everything with the
keywords
because there's so much long tail dsas
will capture that or now you have a
five-page website
google will find nothing new with dsa's
it's a waste of time
right and so think through those types
of questions and if you are
you know one of the managers on a call
here
always ask this question right to to any
agents you might hire
because if people blankly say yes we
should do it and they're like well
because google says is a good idea
they haven't thought through their
philosophy of managing search
right so it's often a good question to
start separating out
who follows google's best practices
versus who thinks on their own
and i'm not saying google's best
practices are slowly bad but you just
want to make sure they
their opinion they formed was based on
some factor or some way they want to
manage
things you know and this gets then
further
into what do you believe should be used
such as
an ad testing do you just use google's
optimize feature do not use it right
and this is often one of those
simple questions that will start
separating people
based upon how much they truly know
about search
so you'll have some we're like you know
what if we are
focused on other areas of the account
right now we're not testing ads a lot
we may use optimize because that's not
our primary focus so let's let google
manage this
and then but in these campaigns we're
doing some serious ad testing
we're actually um setting manual bids so
we do want to go for the rotating
definitely to understand the data
differences
right in this is one of those areas
where you can start to see
okay this person brings independent
thought
to how are our accounts being managed
versus they just follow a checkbox that
google says and follow google
suggestions
so this is like sort of like the initial
part right
what do you know let's start with the
basics match types and ads and ad
rotation
do you have an overall idea of how these
things fit
do you believe in always google do you
temper google do you do it on your own
right and this that's that first stage
of thoughts
then we get into the more controversial
parts
how do you bid right what kind of
bidding do you prefer
and and this is where you may have some
people are like
we love you know google's automated
bidding has done great for us
we always test it we look at it but if
it doesn't work we pull it apart
versus others um we
have a lot of unique in-house data
google doesn't have
and we like to feed our own data for
bidding
on top of right any
other pl any other characteristics of a
user audience holiday what not
so to be able to do those two things in
combination
we must do manual bidding right and this
gets into
real some some pretty deep conversations
about
you know are you hands on are you hands
off do you use third party data do you
just roll in first party data
are you bringing in a new data source
even if it's from your own crm system
are you letting google do the heavy
lifting and again there's not right or
wrong answers here
right it's you know you may have
sometimes you've got this great first
party data
but we're in insurance and
our lawyers question whether we can use
some of this
so even though we think we could do a
better job if we used it
our lawyers won't let us so therefore we
just rely on on
google's automated building to learn
some characteristic stuff and do it for
us
um but it's a good place to introduce
right how well do you work with other
systems
with other data sources how does this
look right big picture for the
advertiser for you to work on
another simple question are smart
campaigns smart
um and and there are smart campaigns are
highly highly controversial in the
industry
some people love them they think they're
the best things
ever hey look we can just upload our
merchant feed to google merchant center
we turn on smart campaign we sit back
and google does
all the work and they do a pretty good
job right and then you with the other
side who's like
we tested them um we found
that it really just turned into another
remarketing campaign
are yeah they hit the metric goals but
we didn't get
net new customers we just resold the old
customers
we don't like them but hey google is
testing a new feature to
let us actually figure out that mixture
of net new versus repeat
so we'll give another chance right and
this again
lets you have those conversations about
thinking through potential implications
of even something as simple as
campaign type right so then
but that second set of questions right
the bidding the campaign type so forth
really get into some more the third
party data stuff
um how someone works with it are they
flexible in it
um how much will they sort of add to the
the data you're using in the account
then we we pull back a little bit bigger
picture right and say okay so
so we understand you have an idea about
match types we understand your
philosophy and ads and the creation
and the math the bidding part so
how do you how do you manage then big
picture
right so you'll you'll often have
statements from someone
we want a 30 cpa for the accounts you're
profitable right
so that sounds like okay account why you
want to start off cpa
but then that you'll say all right but
we want to also
increase the awareness of our products
well
increasing awareness of products is
a completely different goal um that
shouldn't be
measured on a target cpa basis
so we have a couple options of how we
would
we want to talk through something like
this with someone
right one would be okay it sounds like
we just need
different budgets for these things to
separate them out
another one is all right so we're going
to focus
on the 25 cpa for the keywords that can
get conversions
put these new keywords over here to
spread awareness
as long as the blended data comes into
30 we've hit the account goals
right and so this especially if you're
working with an
agency or someone who's going to do some
budget management
this is a really good conversation
because it gets into
how flexible are they managing budgets
how rigid
what do they think about the overall
goals and how that fits your budget
to what's possible so great conversation
to have
but that's the goal part but goals of
course are
based on how you want to measure a goal
so then you get into one of the most
controversial conversations you could
potentially have
attribution models so
how should we do what model should we
use
and in this there is
no right or wrong answer whatsoever with
attribution models
um there's often you'll use all of them
at once depending on what you're trying
to examine and if you haven't done a lot
of attribution model
we have some webinars we've done in the
past
that go through this in in incredible
detail
of the different models when to use each
model type so that data
sits in simple one two um
but this gets into right if you're using
you know position based well okay so
are you a a type of company
who spends some money on awareness and
some money on closing the deal
and you just want to kind of watch the
credit in the middle
are you focused only on growth are you
focused only on last click
and while it's an interesting
conversation
you know last click sometimes gets this
terrible wrap right oh last click it's
so you know 1999 she used last click
i was working on an account a couple
weeks ago and
last click was by far their best choice
um if multiple things were tested multi
as looked at
it was by far the best choice and so
every model
in the proper context has really good
uses to it
but this gets into again are you doing
attribution modeling only by channel so
we're talking
you do an attribution model just for
google ads
are you going to you know if you're in
house
and you're using organic and google ads
and bing ads in facebook and twitter and
you're doing guest posts and whatnot
are you doing a cross-channel
attribution model
right which is obviously much heavier in
the data and analysis part
to pull it off correctly but good
conversation to have do they just rely
on one thing
um do they always just pick time decay
because that's what
people say to use if you don't have an
idea or they have
a philosophy behind how attribution
should be
done for accounts
but then we get into to budget
management right so how do you manage
budgets
do you do campaign budgets account
budget shared budgets
and good philosophy questions right
should budgets be capped
if you tell us hey we want
a 300 percent ross well then the
question is
if you want a thermostat realize can we
just keep spending as long as we keep
that bill in mind right so if we can
spend a thousand dollars a month at 300
or we could spend a hundred thousand and
still hit three 300 percent
should we keep spending right some some
companies
are open-ended budgets if you hit
stringent goals
others are like no we budgets are
quarterly set by corporate and they can
never ever be changed they're set in
stone on a quarterly basis
um you know and so what does that kind
of conversation again
look like on a budget what's your
flexibility
um if you are you know in-house hiring
agency
um they're exp ex some agencies
rightfully
um should push back on fixed budgets
because if you sort of look
at the seasonality of any business
spending the same amount in your peak
season versus your low season
doesn't make sense when you have a
better conversion values your peak
season
right so naturally they would want to
split up the budgets
even if you have a fixed annual budget
they probably shouldn't divide it by 12
right they should look at will peak
season we have more chances to get
conversion at better conversion rates
we should put more money here than just
saying
equal budget of course the course the
whole year and try to hit monthly run
rates
right that's a very basic way of doing
it it's a way of doing it but it's not a
great way of doing it
so budget management good conversation
if you are hiring someone or you're
getting an agency
they're managing some of your money
right so how do they actually look after
your money
um more controversial ones right so
do you do campaigns by device
do you consolidate campaigns do you do
mobile only because you have
different offers for mobile or you're
pushing certain apps you want to do on
mobile that you don't push on desktop
right how do you manage that the
difference
between devices is it just a bit
modifier is that we thought altogether
like google doc made a bidding figure it
out
or do you you know really sit down and
think about the user experience
the ad message what does the
search experience look like by device
because if you look at
you know desktop devices often you will
see
three ads four ads top of page all four
ads type of page get visibility
right obviously top one gets better ctr
but all four get visibility
on a lot of mobile devices often add one
gets all the visibility or add one and
two get it
and and that three doesn't get any at
all so
do you want to look at your average
positions and your top of page rates and
absolute page rates
by devices in how you do your budget
management and your bidding
in some cases it won't matter if your
goal was a thirty dollar cpa
really doesn't matter how it sits across
devices um
if the goal is increasing some
awarenesses ability
then all sudden that top of page rate by
device
becomes an important consideration
and with that i'm going to take just a
moment
um and and let stuart run a second poll
here
thank you brad but um just as i'm
getting ready to run the
poll are there a couple questions about
basic terms and if you could
just um give a quick definition
sure uh rsa versus tsa
cpa and roast sure so
um rsa stands for responsive search ads
they're an ad format where you give
google a bunch of assets you give google
some headlines some description lines
and google mixes and matches all them
together to show the
end ad to the user right versus what we
call an eta expanded text ad
you design the ad yourself and you know
exactly what a user sees
so the reason is controversial is the
question is
if you give a computer a bunch of ad
lines and say
make this good for a human right and if
you have
four headline ones four headline twos
four headline threes and four
descriptions
you're talking uh roughly 30 000
potential combinations
um so do you trust a computer
to figure out how to show an ad which is
a persuasion device to a human versus
write it yourself
um and then dsa is dynamic search ad
meaning you tell google a part of your
website
that you want to show relevant ads for
and then
if the search term matches part of that
website
google builds an ad and shows it to the
user
so you don't have control over the
keywords
on the dynamic search side right and
google's building the ad for you you get
to write descriptions and stuff
so do you trust a computer pick some
keywords and write an ad
without human intervention um in what
the creative process looks like in the
targeting process looks like
um cpa is cost per acquisition or cost
per conversion
so this is how much you want to pay per
conversion row asses return on ad spend
um sometimes confused with return on
investment roi they're slightly
different
um it's just a way of measuring hey we
we spent a dollar we made two dollars so
we have a
200 percent return on ad spent
thank you and now i'm going to open the
poll which is
pretty straightforward what digital
marketing skills
do our audience members currently use
so on your job today which of these
digital marketing tools and skills
do you use now
and again i'll just keep this open for
about a minute longer
and today of course we're talking about
ppc and related topics but
digital marketing encompasses
a number of different skills
give you about 20 seconds more to finish
your answers and hit submit
we'll get the results five
four three two
one
and
looking at
a pretty even mix of the different
skills
with social media being a little bit
more
popular and answered
so any of that surprising brad um
knowing that we're doing paid search
social surprises me a little bit
but um which it's interesting because
when we're talking a lot of data today
writing a lot of philosophy and stuff
and it applies more to social and people
realize
as you know early on in social media's
history it was a
uh a communication method with users
um and and actually early on it was a
broadcast mechanism right then it became
a communication method
and over the past you know two to three
years maybe four years
it has increasingly been measured as a
response channel
i'm meaning hey you know we have the
free social media just like free organic
right the free social media which is
a conversation but we do measure
in various ways how that works and then
we've got the paid side which
initially was you know measured in likes
and tweets and reshares and stuff
and the same of applications of
attribution bidding etc we talk about
paid search has been applied to social
the last few years and become a much
more data driven industry
um than it was you know half dozen years
ago so
it it surprised me a little bit but in a
and again i see where uh
social is going a much more mathematical
route like paid search has been
all right so we'll see how that goes
yeah let's go ahead
all right so all right so our first
other questions right
it really gets into things like do you
know what you're doing
match types ads etc um do you
have a philosophy of thinking through
the creative right the responsive versus
eta
um how do you feel about bidding
philosophies
do you just apply anything google says
or do you have a reason you apply it
um how much do you do some testing right
that's sort of
that's step one and then we start
getting
into a bit more of the complex stuff
right so again if you're if this is your
first interview the company
you won't be asking these questions if
you are doing a you're interviewing for
a team lead or
you're um an in-house person hiring an
agency
right getting into how should our data
flow
are we missing pieces of data
do we have things that we have access to
we're not properly leveraging right
that's that bigger question right if
you're using
salesforce data and salesforce data is
not being pushed back into you know your
google
being yelp whatever a facebook bid
system
then you're not using salesforce
correctly even though you have this data
if you know you i was working the
company a while ago they
you know because they're they're
incredibly siloed
um they had gotten all these
audience metrics finally into place and
they had done
um two different audience measurement
systems
but the paid search team didn't actually
know it was done it was never
it took a couple months long longer than
it should have
um to start getting integrated right in
and so
do you understand your data how it flows
where you can introduce new data
into your stuff are there places where
you start looking and say
hey we if we used you know this
third-party api
we could start doing you know
predictions off of
you know sports teams weather or
whatever it happens to be
and feed that back in which gives us an
indication of how people are going to
change
behaviors or convert and so this
is you know data integration
data movement how data talks to each
other correctly how things are tracked
has you know the last five six years
ha and his only getting tuned has been
increasingly important part of this
conversation
especially as we see you know
third-party cookies dying or they're
getting highly limited
um at times first party cookies being
put on
you know time stamps of how long they'll
live before they get removed
the the way data moves around and talks
um
if your executive level or your team
lead level
is an important part of the conversation
is it important for our audience here to
know what these
uh data flow descriptors all right
not necessarily right so in this case
right i could explain this just let
people get this right so
here we have an advertiser this is a
friend of mine's account
and we've got you know where we spend
money right google yelp and bing
then right google puts what they call a
g
[ __ ] id on the clicks microsoft uses an
ms
click id so data from these three flows
into salesforce
through the website so there's a website
visit here right
then we have this is google search
console which is a bid system being used
so then this data right talks back to
bing and pushes data back to bing
um yelp data feeds directly in here
again
um we have our our salesforce data goes
in here this is where google bids are
being set which is why you don't see the
google data here
um it's it's naturally integrated um
dialog tech is a call tracking system
we have ion on a landing page system so
they are also collecting um the g
[ __ ] id the m [ __ ] id lid is yelp
um and pushing down to the sales force
so everything sits in salesforce
in the end right and pushes back
to their bid system now that doesn't
help on the audience so then you've got
your audience data your spend data
that's being pushed into tableau this is
a reporting system so that they can
analyze
right individual characteristics into
tableau
then regional capacity is also bringing
in
some audience data matching with some
salesforce data matching with a few
other things
um into reporting to understand
and segment data via their email system
their audience systems etc
for various ways they may want to change
target in the future
um they're a company who
is is reliant on weather
in various ways right if you think again
if you let's take out code for a second
um
i know it's a tough one to take out but
let's just go back to a normal world for
a moment
if it rains more people go to the movies
um if it's a really sunny weekend it's a
look cooler or more people go camping
if it is a forecast of snow
in regions that don't get it then
fireplace sales increase
so they use their their weather data
then to bring in
reporting which then they and and take
this data
this goes back into their bid system
which then puts us back out bids
um and so you know this is you and i
have to know how this works
and every company is super different in
how this would work
but that's an example of one company um
in in how they're sort of marketing
stack we said it's our marketing stack
essentially
right this this is not including email
and all the other stuff but this is part
of their
uh marketing stack from a top level
standpoint
hopefully i didn't lose everyone with
that like that makes sense than most
people but
it they get complicated um in how data
flows and so
thinking through right are we you know
we've got google who sends data and
we're collecting it but oh
our audience data dead ends at our
reporting system but doesn't actually
get moved to our bid system means
we have data we're not properly using
i mean and so flow charting things so
for those who have been on a few
webinars that i do
i i love flow charts because it's the
clean way of looking through things i'm
you'll see them in most decks
some sort of flowchart usually cleaner
than this one but some sort of flow
chart because
it just gives you an idea of how exactly
something goes and what the decision is
and where dead ends
and gets lost
with that um
so how do you do reporting right so this
is is really important question for
people to talk through
because you're spending money you're
getting results
do you get full um
transparency into the results are you
allowed to see how you do by devices
are you allowed to see how some of these
new campaign experiments are going
um do you get commentary along with it
so
reporting is is an underdone
conversation
at times um because you really want to
know
how much data you have access to and
often we kind of use the the one cheater
rule meaning
you know the person who is in charge of
the the
the accounts funding right which is
could be a pvc team lead could be a
director level whoever it is
right they get a full data full data
dump of everything
in a usable manner and then they often
pull off a few sheets and give it to
their boss
reporter and then they pull off a few
sheets and give it to their boss
reporting
until it gets to the you know the
c-level executives
who get a single sheet of paper because
that's all they care about they don't
want all the details
right so do you make reporting easy as
reports get set up a ladder in a
corporation
so or does someone have to reformat it
to give it to their boss reforms to give
it to their boss right
it should really be one report that just
gets you know a few sheets pulled off
the back
as it goes up the chain um
audiences right this again gets into
hey do you know what you're doing but b
can you think
through those situations right everyone
generates
huge amount of data these days in
applying that with audience
characteristics be it
ages genders people who like cameras
people who go to sporting events
people who have been at home way too
long right whatever it is
um you can you can start to look at what
are the audience types and how do you
leverage them
i mean it's a really good question and
and this gets also into bringing in your
own data so if you've got
an email system and your email system is
tracking
average checkout values on your
e-commerce site
right so that you can segment out these
are
um repeat high value purchasers versus
one-time purchasers or first purchasers
can we use that to feed it back into our
paid search to
manage them differently now as soon as
we get into
audiences in this usage know your
country rules
um every country is different in how
they manage rules
you have you know eu has one set
california's got something you've got
you know rest of the us you have
different rules in in uk
um and so just know your country rules
and how that can work
remarketing is it worthwhile right
sometimes you get a cmo who's like
aren't we really just paying twice the
same conversion
um in other places remarketing is
incredibly important
um in this comp uh if you you know sort
of look at this right
path link is half length is how many
times someone came to this site
so when someone came to this website
once they were 47 of this company's
conversions
they were only 21 of their revenue
so people who bought on a single
purchase bought a lot of stuff
but but i'm sorry about frequently but
very very low dollar amounts
people who came to the site more than 12
times right that's a lot of repeat
visits
they were only 10 of their conversions
right so it was
and from up here like how often how many
conversions was a very small number
that 10 of people was 32
of their total revenue right so
obviously people who came back
repeatedly
before buying had really huge purchases
and so the question isn't how do you
keep bringing them
back and how do you segment them or
bring them back and so looking through
you know remarketing and and how the
channels play together
good conversation um
how can you use custom data right i mean
this
is is one thing we've seen over the past
you know six to eight months with with
covid
is you'll have countries
where individual population are living
under different rules so you'll have
some
they can't go to their house others they
can go out of their house
to a essential business others
they can go to sporting events others
they can go to a sporting event
if they can't but there can't be more
than x number of people in this in the
stadium
right and so things are so fragmented
in what can and can't be done that
you'll
often see lists these days
which look at things like recovery phase
dates or
phases of recovered span um
you know worked on a very smart ad
campaign for
someone it was like you know 25 of smart
tvs until
and then we did geographic lists of most
popular sports teams that would start
their season next on normal conditions
by individual city so that that way you
would
every ad would be 25 smart tvs until
cowboy games are back or united
manchester games are back whoever
happened
it happens to be um and and that's a way
of
not using personal data because you're
not using a user's you know first party
data here
you're just using a location data to
customize some of the ads and speak to
users and so we have seen them with
covid
more people being creative in bringing
in data to do some ad customizers
um with individuals whether it's virtual
appointments versus
some people still talk about in person
or custom in person or safe in person
different things um apps
should your ads run on apps should they
not run on apps
is there why and then why right are some
apps worthwhile
others aren't what's your app
advertising
philosophy um how do you design tests
right this gets again into your uh
you're more team leads
more agencies but how do you design
tests and you know if someone's like hey
we're thinking uh in this case right
it's like someone is like you know we're
thinking about
um advertising in in latvia we don't do
any things in latvia now
but we want to see how latvia
converts differently than estonia or
romania
so how can we lay out a test to look at
the differences to understand how we
need to
push our products just in that region
differently than some of the surrounding
areas
right so how does that conversation go
when you have that type of conversation
all right now back into organization
right so
what's your daily routine how do you
track changes
are you calendar are you project
management
um we have done a two or three different
webinars
purely on managing paid search as a
project um and so if you're looking to
be
just more organized and getting things
done there's a couple really good ones
in there
i'm historically getting into how
product management works and
and doing product based marketing
campaigns
um and so when you think about i say
just a job interview
right things that are essential
these days obviously i probably said
data a hundred times in the past
45 minutes um so when you think about
things you must know right
excel obviously but in in reality
95 of all excel skills you're going to
use
in in paid search is going to be your
filtering views and basic formulas right
sums and so forth pivot tables
pivot tables are essential on pivot
table charts
and vlookup in reality if you can get
through those few things in excel
you can analyze anything in page search
right but you have to be able to just
basically
do a pivot table and a chart on top of
it which you know your first one takes a
while your 10th takes like 30 seconds
um but it lets you make you know a
report like what's your that's
that uh an image there um
is you know less than two minutes of
work
um if you know what you're doing if you
don't that could take someone an hour to
try to figure out
how to do all that layering and there's
a secondary and a primary
access i'm in a single pivot table chart
right so it's not super complicated
but before you start you know doing
reports and paid search and doing
interviewees and or if you're
interviewing someone
um i've seen interview processes where
they'll give someone an excel sheet and
say
all right tell me the answer to this or
show me this chart
and just to make sure the person
actually has the skills
and they'll watch someone live put
together right a chart
or or whatever in excel to make sure
they really have those skills because
everyone's like yeah i can do excel
but can you really like can you really
manage the numbers
um are you certified right so are you a
google partner
are you om cp certified which of course
is is
simply learned as part of the
organization that does omc
certifications
do you are you certified do you have a
sustainable approval saying
we know what we're doing um super
important
always part of conversations so
you know things to think about right so
number one
know your information or if you're still
struggling with
what are the different ad types how to
match types work
right that's step one is to you know get
your certification by going through
training
so you have definitive answers on a sort
of definition style right textbook
definitions
of yes these are the match types this is
how they function
we know that um that will get you an
entry-level job it might even get you a
you know a paid search job it shouldn't
give you a team lead or if you're a
hiring manager
right that's a great entry-level
position without even a philosophy right
they
they know their definitions they can get
through a good practice conversation
they're they're they should you know
they good job candidate
step two then is to develop your ppc
philosophy
all right so you know how these things
work
based upon your vision of the world how
you think
advertising works and so forth why would
you make certain decisions
um now again based on the company you're
working with and knowing
they may have regulations or not have
regulations or they're super creative or
they're not right you you can have your
philosophy but still
right talk that within how the company
functions to make sure you know
you guys are compatible um if you're
gonna do an interview of course
research the company first i mean that's
always very important is to research
just to
understand what they're doing and why
they do it
um consider how then you know your
philosophy
and the companies interact so you might
like yeah i like to this way but you
know what they do it that way and i
don't really care
i'll just go with the way they do it all
right that of course that happens right
people want to be nice and presentable
um to the company that they want to be
hired by but that'll let you have that
that successful interview know whether
you're the interviewee you're the
company or hiring someone
or you're the person who who's looking
to be hired or you're an agency
interviewing a new possible new client
or someone who's going to interview an
agency right
it's first do they know what they're
doing can they take that
and form a philosophy out of it meaning
they can take just definitions
and think through how that works in the
real world
did they take the time to research us i
mean i've seen agencies
who hop on a call with you know a large
company
and be like okay so what do you guys do
and
if you're an agent senior you know
you're getting on a call with five
people at a company maybe you should
take a few minutes to know what they do
beforehand just to sound informed right
that that you know even 10 15 minutes
it's it's important for 15 minutes
think through and then that's when that
that successful interview whether it's
you know a sales call an interview for a
job interview for a new hire
an agency interviewing a client a client
every age whatever it is
um we'll have a good interview from that
and with that i'm going to hand it back
to stewart
for our third poll and then we will
we'll come back and get through any
other q and a and so forth we have
thanks and this next poll
talks about the flip side of the last
one which is
when you look ahead in your career what
are the new skills
in digital marketing that you'd like to
acquire
um what are you most interested in
learning adding to your
particular personal toolbox
so we'll keep this open again for about
a minute or so
and we hope
webinar has sparked
some interesting questions in your
minds about you know what else do i need
to know about digital marketing
to be successful
and i'll give you about 20 seconds and
i'll share the pull results
so get your answers in we're ending in 5
4 3 two
one
and
we have a number of people who'd like to
get a broad overview
general all skills education but
um
seo and pp's ppc send to tend to be the
uh less popular and website conversion
optimization
tend to be the most popular answers so
again is anything surprising there brad
no and and so this gets into i'm gonna
take like one minute here before we get
the question so this gets into
um there's there's clearly a lot of
people who are
newer on this right and there's some
managers and stuff here too
but when you think about digital
marketing
um usually the way to do this industry
right
is to number one get a broad overview
right understand the basics of social
and mobile and email and paid and
everything
because then you can even have good
conversations across departments so even
if you're a c-level executive
taking a 101 course to understand all
the
how all the different ones work and how
they can fit together
great starting place step two
often it's let's now drive traffic to
our website
we get social seo paid search right
however you wanna do that
let's drive traffic um and then let's
convert the traffic which is website
conversion
what surprises me is that analytics
isn't on here um
because then you you you convert the
traffic and then you have to measure the
data right which is the analytic side
um and so usually people
first get started basics second webs um
second traffic driver
third conversion fourth analytics that
symbol is love analytics and course
starting analytics and there's nothing
wrong with that
um you'll eventually regardless your
discipline do some analytics uh
research as well
okay and i'll add that to future polls
yeah it's just i you know i mean how'd
you do right that's analytics um
right so let's move on then to the
q a all right let's have some questions
yeah we have a few questions or what a
youtube
viewer asks uh are there any
prerequisites for ppc
um so training obviously not
right before you manage a paid search
account you should
so the difference in say paid search and
organic let's just start for a second
right
or organic if you
let's say you sit down and you work on a
site and and you put
time investment right which organic
structural time investment although if
you're a manager your time investment
also includes hiring people so there's a
monetary investment
um and and if you make a mistake you can
fix it right
paid search is about spending money to
get results
so if you make some big mistakes and
paid that money is gone google now owns
that money
and and so when you think of doing paid
advertising it scares some people
because the money is being spent a
credit card is being charged
um and so it is important paid search to
truly have
a a good education first to know what
you're doing or to
and then often you'll join a team and
work under someone first who can
you know kind of watch over you that's
why you see a lot of affiliates start on
the organic
side because they can build a website
they can send traffic to their websites
and they don't have they can spend time
of course not spending a lot of money
um learning the craft and so you know i
don't want to say because seo is
incredibly complicated as well so i'm
not putting that down at all it's
it's just a different way of writing a
check versus time investments
um but so i would not do paid search
until you truly have
understood the nuances of how things
work and at least have a
a solid one-on-one education at a
minimum
well that leads to a related question
from another youtube viewer kesho who
asks uh how can i learn ppc from scratch
oh simple i mean you're on a simpler
webinar simply learn has some uh
um fantastic courses on
on paid search so they've got you know
for those of you who want that overview
the um the 101 the digital foundation
course level is called
is a great intro to everything
and then the the paid search classes the
foundation and mastery at simple learn
will give you the omcp certification and
really walk you through
um all the stuff we've talked about
today but
it how it works and then ideas on
why we do it that way right which gets
into some of the philosophy and
and developing a philosophy as well as
just a yes no answer of how things
function
thank you um deepak
uh asks what services would you offer
your first
smm a client and what skills are needed
to run
okay sorry you say sma
swma what does that mean
swma s m m
i'm sorry s-m-m-a
is that social media what is that's
what's the acronym
for he hasn't uh defined that so let's
move on to a different question
okay i'm not positive what smma is okay
yeah
um so sam asks
uh how would you decide which ppc
strategy to use for
a given campaign oh sure right so that
is looking at what
is needed based upon um the client's
needs
based upon their budget um and
and so there is no way of just saying
this is how to do it right it's more
everyone is tailored slightly
differently um
you know if you're you know plumber
you're gonna focus more on the calls and
the mobile side of things
and often an immediate response of
things
if it's e-commerce you're going to look
at a lot more of the feed side
shopping ads and yeah remarketing and so
it's more paid search has
i mean thousands of potential options
right it's looking at here's the menu of
options here's they fit together let's
look at
an individual accounts needs and
then say here's based upon what they
need
how they want to manage it how they want
to measure it
um the the necessary data or data
restrictions
um this is how that would be built and
then managed at least to start until you
can
you know look at any possible
refinements based on what happened in
the results
giving a true result on uh true ranch in
that one i
you know i'll run facebook and twitter
ad campaigns and linkedin ad campaigns
but from a pure agency standpoint you're
often getting into community management
as well that is not my not my forte so i
would not start answering community
management questions
yeah we have other courses that deal
with uh
social media marketing so um keep tuned
for a future webinar we're going to be
doing one on that subject
and um finally um
abdi asks where can we get the project
management webinar you were talking
about
sure so the archives that simply learn
should have it if you just search to
simply learn a youtube channel
um for like managing paid search like a
project
managing ppc like a project um it should
show up in the results
for the the previous webinars that
simply learn
and we're coming up on time
to wrap it up there there are a couple
of other questions that i made
sent to you separately but thank you for
that brad
and um so i think um
people can keep in touch with you at bg
theory
on twitter are there other channels that
you'd
uh mention um i linked in i'm on
linkedin all the time too if you just
search me at linkedin you'll easily find
me
those are probably the the best too well
we want to thank you
for being here brad and sharing your
knowledge with the audience
um yeah i have tbd listed here
our next webinar is actually on november
10th
and um it is in
cyber security so uh if you are
interested
in cyber security contact stewart
dot creek simply learn
which is in your webex invitation
and i can send you information about
that but we will be sending out a
promotion
for that next webinar uh in our
follow-ups
from this webinar so uh keep in touch
with us
at linkedin at twitter
um and on facebook and we look forward
to having you at future simply learn
webinars
thank you all for being here and thank
you sir for hosting us
appreciate it and that concludes our
webinar for today
you